So this is the last lecture.
So what I thought I'd do is
I try to tell you what sense I've made
over the course of
20 how long have I been thinking about
this?
30 years,
30 years of thinking about the sorts of
things that I've been teaching you.
I'm going to
try to integrate the things that we
talked about over the semester and tell
you what I think they add up to.
It's obviously it's very difficult to
make them add up to to one comprehensive
thing because we talked a lot about a
lot of different things and they weren't
necessarily
non contradictory,
which doesn't bother me that much,
you know,
because I like to think of theories as
tools rather than as final statements
about the nature of objective reality.
And you can have tools of different
shapes and
just because they don't all fit together
in some kind of gigantic metta tool
doesn't mean that they're not useful
piece by piece.
And that's a good way of thinking.
I especially,
I think about the different personality
theories that we've discussed because as
far as I can tell,
each of them has a valuable place in
trying to understand all the things that
happened to people.
Not only all the things that happen to
people in their lives,
but really also what life is and what it
can be.
So,
but I'm going to tell you how I've
integrated this.
Um,
I think the first thing that's worth
thinking about is what is it that we're
thinking about?
And I think that those are the,
you know,
two of the two words that signify this
sort of greatest of philosophical
mysteries,
right?
It's like what's the nature of being an,
and I liked the phenomenological
approach to that because for me being
this is,
this is the same sort of tack that
Heidegger took,
is that being,
is what you experience at certainly your
being.
And that's,
that's really what your primary
primarily unnecessarily concerned about.
And that includes the subjective and
psychology has to take account of that.
It's sort of unique among the sciences
in a sense,
is that psychology cannot ignore
subjectivity.
Biology can ignore subjectivity and soak
in physics.
Well mostly,
but psychology stuck right in the middle
of the objective and the subjective and
it has to take both into consideration.
And that's especially true when you also
consider that psychology is an applied
science or art depending on how you look
at it.
And it also has to deal with issues of,
because it has to deal with issues of
optimal being in suboptimal being or or
suffering and health,
something like that.
So it has to be very comprehensive.
And roughly speaking,
I suppose you could think about being as
what is currently and becoming as how
that's going to transform,
but it's more than how it's going to
transform to because it's also how it
should transform.
And it seems to me that when you're
wrestling with the fundamental questions
of your life,
you have to wrestle with both of those
propositions.
You have to figure out what it is that's
here and now and where you are and what
you are.
And then you have to figure out what
you're going to do about that.
And hypothetically,
at least in principle,
it seems like people are generally
motivated to attempt to make it better.
And so then you have to figure out what
constitutes better.
And now not also means that you are
instantly into the domain of values.
And not only is there an impetus to make
it better,
but there's also the fact that while
you're trying to make things better,
you're also fighting against entropy
itself.
The tendency of complicated things to
fall apart or complex things to fall
apart.
And so it requires energy to make things
better.
It even requires energy just to keep
things the way they are.
So in some sense life is an uphill
battle because you're pushing against
great forces that,
that act in opposition to your
existence.
And I suppose in some sense,
that's the fundamental basis of
existential thinking,
which is a form of thinking that I'm
also fond of because the existentialists
make the claim that existence itself is
a problem.
And so that means that in some sense,
psychopathology is built right into the
nature of human existence.
And it's partly because we're limited
and we suffer because of that.
And the flip side of that as well,
we're limited and we're working against
forces that are in many ways greater
than we are and that are pushing in the
opposite direction.
So life is being and becoming and it's
also the problem of being and becoming
and that's what you're stuck with and
it's kind of useful to know what you're
stuck with I think because it stops you
from being isolated because everybody's
also stuck with that.
It also makes you understand that if you
have a problem that doesn't necessarily
mean there's something wrong with you,
it's just that you're alive,
then that's a problem.
And you know,
of course that can get so complicated
that it's unbearable.
But the central like,
you know,
people think in some sense are people
are inclined to think that
if life was operating optimally you'd be
happy or something like that.
And I think that that's an unreasonable
hope in some ways because it's life
itself is so complicated because of its
of its fundamental essence that the idea
that you can exist in some optimized
state on a constant basis is,
well it's,
it's just,
that's just not how it is.
So you have to,
when you mature and when you become
wiser,
you have to take into account what the
actual limitations are and then you have
to figure out a way that you can exist.
Not so much despite that,
but well,
taking that into account and it seems to
me that it's possible to do that.
And one idea is that you can hide from
that.
I think the idea of positive illusions
is like that,
that you know,
you need to construct defenses against
the nature of the world.
Terror management theory posits that as
well.
You know,
the,
the sort of ideas that life itself is so
terrible that you have to build defenses
against it.
And some of those defenses have the
nature of positive illusions.
But I don't buy that.
I think that people are tough.
They're a lot tougher than they think.
And so I think that people are capable
of facing up to reality.
Even though reality as it's experienced
is fundamentally tragic.
That's tragic because people are
limited.
So that's sort of the domain that you're
in.
And I think that like if psych for
psychology to be something that's
profound,
I can't skirt those issues,
it has to address them directly.
And that's difficult because they're not
merely objective problems,
they're also subjective problems.
And it isn't all that obvious how
science can deal with,
with subjective problems.
But we're not dealing with science in
psychology.
We're dealing with human being in the
phenomenal logical sense.
And so at least that's how it looks to
me.
And so
I've found the sorts of things that I've
taught you extremely useful in
addressing some of these partially
addressing at least some of these
fundamental problems.
So here's a couple of ways of looking at
domains of knowledge in relationship to
those problems.
So the problem of being and becoming is
also the problem of what is and what
should be.
And Science,
it seems to me concentrates primarily on
a subset of what is unknown because
it's,
it's concerned with the structure of the
world as it presents itself,
but not to subjectivity precisely but to
the collective mind.
And so the rule with sciences,
well if more than one person can detect
it at the same time,
then it might actually be real.
Or at least it's real scientifically.
And that's a pretty,
that's a pretty useful tool.
And I think it's partly useful because
it helps us differentiate our knowledge
in a way that makes it more and more
practically useful.
We need to know the difference between
what we can both experience and what
only you can experience and what only I
can experience.
And and by,
by continually continually clarifying
that what's happened is we've built a
much better and much more delineated
understanding of the ground,
of our shared experience.
And that's also allowed us to develop
all sorts of tools and technologies that
have also that we've also chosen in most
cases to put,
to work increasing our general quality
of life and wellbeing.
So,
so the science end of things has worked
pretty well.
It's become hyper developed over the
last 500 years and knots.
That's good thing.
But it's left some things in the lurch,
I believe,
and no one we talked about when we
talked about Nietzsche,
Nietzsche,
and his idea of the death of God.
We talked about one of the consequences
of the rise of this,
of science has knowledge.
And because science can say that the
reality it deals with is the shared ix
is the reality of shared experience.
But it also tends to go farther than
that.
And it's,
and to say that there is no other real
reality,
but what shared experience presents to
us,
and that's where things get troublesome.
Because first of all,
from from a subjective perspective,
that just doesn't seem to be true.
I mean,
you can't,
it isn't obvious how you can understand
the relationship between the fact that
you have your subjective experience and,
and,
and the fact of the objective world.
We don't know how to put those two
things together and merely ignoring the
subjective while that that causes
problems.
Because of course,
that's what you're primarily stuck with
and it's the primary problem.
You know,
how do you deal with your isolated
individual existence and what do you
make of it?
And Science in some senses,
it can't answer those questions,
but it shouldn't.
That shouldn't necessarily lead us to
the conclusion that such and such
questions shouldn't be posed or that
they don't have to be answered.
I they do have to be answered because
they're still part of the domain of
problems that beset human beings.
So it seems to me that for a
comprehensive picture of experience or
of being,
you have to use two domains of analysis
and one is the scientific domain and the
other is fundamentally the moral domain.
And the moral domain for me isn't I not
really saying precisely that the moral
domain is the difference between right
and wrong.
Although I think that that's part of it.
The moral domain is actually a broader
domain of questions,
which is,
well,
how should yakked?
Because knowing what is is from a
scientific perspective does not give you
a clear understanding of how you should
progress through life.
And because we're embodied creatures and
because we move and because we're
capable of transforming the world,
both with our consciousness and our,
like with our consciousness and our
communication and our actions,
there's no escaping the problem of how
you should act.
And then it's an even more complicated
problem because it's not only how you
should act because of your limitations
and your skills,
but how you should,
you should act given that there's all
these other creatures wandering around
that are asking the same questions and
trying to act just like you are.
So other human beings.
And then of course the fact of the,
the world,
the nonhuman,
the living nonhuman world as well,
which is something that you have to have
a relationship with.
And you can't just ignore those
questions because they don't because
they're not easily answered by the
mechanisms of empirical science.
It leaves people bereft.
And when,
when Nisha talked about the death of
God,
I mean what he meant in some sense was
that the claims of science are
sufficiently radical so that it's easy
to take them to mean that the um,
the sort of landscape of stories that
constitute our archaic cultures are
invalid.
Now
it's a complicated problem because it
isn't at all clear to me that the
landscape of stories that make up our
cultural past are in fact scientific
descriptions and I don't think they ever
were,
were.
And the fact that the manner in which
they described the world seems to
contradict what we understand safe from
cosmology.
To me it's basically irrelevant because
they're not dealing with the same
problem but,
but you can see how it would,
it has be been easy for people to become
philosophically confused because it's
not self evident that you meet need more
than one kind of truth to live.
It's not even self evident that there is
more than one kind of truth,
you know?
But why we assumed that there would only
be one kind of truth is a mystery in and
of itself.
It's,
it seems to me that it's related somehow
to,
to the push in humanity for a form of
monotheism in or total a totality of one
theory governs all.
Well maybe that's true in some ultimate
sense,
but it certainly isn't the case that
we're at that point yet.
So we might say,
well,
maybe we need all the kinds of truth we
can get our hands on and all the tools
that we have in order to live properly.
And we can sort out the fact that some
of them seem to coexist paradoxically.
Well we can just live with that for now
and accepted as a necessity that might
become,
you know,
the reason for which might become more
clear across time.
So,
so it seems to me that for psychology to
be a psychologist,
you have to take both of these domains
very seriously.
You have to learn everything you can
about what science has to tell you about
what it is that you're like and what the
world is like.
And then you have to learn everything
you can about what history and culture
and,
and also shared the shared communication
between people tells us about what the
appropriate ways are to ourselves and to
what ends we should be working.
And those are all valid questions and
they,
and if you ignore any of them,
you ignore them at your peril because
you have to know them in order to,
in order to minimize the degree to which
you're going to suffer unnecessarily or
that other people are going to suffer
unnecessarily.
So it's not optional.
You see that this is sort of dichotomous
truth.
The problem of this dichotomous truth
shows up in all sorts of binary
oppositions in terms of forms of
knowledge.
You know,
so there's the,
well there's the objective reality,
which no one reading lives in because
it's a third person perspective,
right?
So it's a hypothetical kind of reality,
but conceptualizing it seems to be very
useful.
And then there's the phenomenological
perspective,
which is your experience is actually
reality and that's what counts.
And those two things aren't the same.
And that's sort of like the difference
between objective and subjective.
And it's sort of like the difference
between scientific and moral and it's
sort of like the difference between
materialistic and mythological.
And so those are all dichotomies are
paradoxical juxtapositions of forms of
conception that seemed to be hitting at
the,
this paradoxical relationship between
being and becoming.
So we considered both sides of these
paradoxical,
uh,
conceptual schemes as we walked through
the class material.
I read you this at the beginning of the
class.
This is from Einstein.
He's trying to clarify what it is that
we're doing.
When we practice science and Einstein
said by the aid of language,
different individuals can to some extent
compare their experiences.
Then it turns out that certain sense
perceptions of different individuals
correspond to each other.
Well for other sense perceptions,
no such correspondence can be
established.
We are accustomed to regard as real
those sense perceptions which are common
to different individuals and which
therefore are in a measure impersonal.
The natural sciences and in particular
the most fundamental of them.
Physics deals with such sense
perceptions.
It's not a,
it's,
it's Einstein and obviously Einstein was
a great thinker.
There are,
there are things missing about this
description of what constitutes science.
Because the other thing that constitutes
science is a description of the
procedures that led to the emergence of
the sentence perception,
right?
You think about how a scientific paper
is written,
it's not only results,
it's method and results.
And the method is how I constituted my
body and time and space to produce these
particular sense perceptions.
And so it's,
it's a way of formalizing behavior and
then pairing it with the consequences of
behavior and then communicating in a
way,
in a way that someone else could
hypothetically duplicate that.
So Einstein's pure focus on sense
perception is not,
it's not complete.
You can't forget about the
systematization of procedures in science
and it's easy to forget that.
But apart from that it's,
you know,
it's a pretty good summary.
And then Shakespeare,
he takes another tack at the whole
problem.
And this is where the rubber hits the
road as far as I'm concerned,
in terms of how you constitute your
individual,
your individual being.
And Shakespeare says,
and it's not a metaphor in many ways,
this all the world's a stage.
And all the men and women,
merely players,
they have their exits and their
entrances and one man in his time plays
many parts.
And so from,
from the Shakespearian pers perspective,
you're,
you're being is more like a play than it
is like,
uh,
like a collection of objective
phenomena.
And then what happens is the play
itself,
like a shakespearian play becomes a more
accurate representation of being than a
scientific description does.
And it's because it plays out it because
it's because it accounts for behavior
and because it plays out the
consequences of behavior from the
subjective perspective.
Because a good play elicits the sort of
passions and emotions and motivations
that are subjectively experienced that
actually character your eyes,
your life as you live it.
So what that means is the play a novel,
a book,
a story is an abstract representation of
reality that's subject to just as much
rigor in terms of conception as a
scientific description of a given thing.
And it's also real,
well,
it depends on what you mean by real,
right?
Because we already found out what the
scientists think of as real.
But there's lots of arguments about that
because I might say,
well
you,
I would judge what you consider real by
watching how you behave,
not by listening to what you say about
the structure of the world.
And that's an existential perspective as
well.
And so then I would note that dis,
regardless of what all of you might say
about what you believe about the nature
of reality,
it's certainly the case that you're
going to act as if your own perceptions,
you're your own subjectivity is real.
So for example,
if something hurts you,
you can think all you want about how
pain is not objective,
but that's not going to get you out of
the painful situation and you're still
going to configure your behavior so that
you're going to do everything you can
even in voluntarily so that you will
work to avoid that pain.
And so you're stuck with acting as if
your subjectivity is real.
And that happens.
That happens at such a deep level that
it supersedes your consciousness,
right?
Like if you,
if you put your arm on a burning stove,
you're going to take your arm away from
that before you even think about it.
So the reality of reality in some sense
of your subjectivity is so deep that you
don't even necessarily have a choice
about it.
So
yeah.
So one of the things that I've,
I've wondered for a long time is what
happens if you take this sort of idea
seriously?
You know that,
that you need the knowledge that is
constituted in stories because it tells
you how to behave and because you need
to know how to behave,
because that's actually one of the
fundamental problems of life.
It might even be the most fundamental
problem of life if you know from a
scientific perspective,
the most fundamental problem is what are
things made of?
It's something like that.
How do they interrelate?
But just because that's a very well
stated problem and just because we've
been able to produce profound in
differentiated answers to it does not
necessarily mean that that is the
problem that almost everyone faces.
And it seems to me it's especially the
case with people.
At your age,
it's like,
well,
what am I going to do?
Seems to me to be the fundamental
problem and soul.
And if the answer to that is,
well,
there's no real guidance for that.
It's just something you have to figure
out for yourself.
Then you know,
that's the sort of thing that makes you
question the utility of knowledge per
se.
And I think it's a weak answer and I
also think it's a wrong answer.
There's lots of,
there are lots of,
there are,
there is no shortage of information
about how to behave and there's no
shortage of information about what
happens if you break the rules of
behavior.
Now there's arguments about what those
rules are and there's no,
it's no doubt that they differ
contextually,
but just something can differ at one
level of analysis and be the same at
another.
Languages are like that,
right?
I mean we all speak a language.
The languages are different,
but they're all languages,
which means they differ at one level of
analysis and there are common had
another.
And how it act is like that too.
And I think piaget is particularly
useful for thinking about that because
piaget is the thinker who I think has
done the most work and trying to
understand how it is that there might
be,
yeah.
A basis for what constitutes morality,
you know,
and Piaget starts with,
with the shakespearian conception,
fundamentally he believes that how to
act is the problem.
And you know,
we're embodied creatures and we're very
mobile and we're very good at
manipulating the world.
We're very good at communicating.
And so any psychology that doesn't take
into account the nature of our
embodiment is a very weak psychology.
And Piaget basically says,
well look,
you know,
you come into the world with some
potential for auction.
It's kind of minimal,
but it's enough to get you going,
right?
It's enough to kick start you in a
sense.
And then as you organize your body and
you're doing this neurologically sort of
from the spine up,
as we discussed,
the,
the manner in which you organize your,
your capability for action and
perception is continually modified by
your social interaction with other.
So,
so it's,
so you're,
you're socialized being is built right
into your motor circuitry.
It's,
it's a pattern.
It's not even a conception.
It's a pattern.
So for example,
when you're breastfeeding,
you have to do it in a manner that
allows your mother to tolerate you.
And so something,
even something as simple as,
as the first ways that you use your lips
and your mouth and,
and the way that you express your
emotions is,
is immediately going to be modified by
the necessity of social interaction and
social interaction can't just proceed
any old way,
right?
So if we have a relationship and it
becomes seriously nonreciprocal,
you're a fool.
If it's nonreciprocal in your direction,
you're a fool to stay with it.
You know,
there's something that's roughly like
the expectation of 50 50 and that's well
that's well established empirically
with,
with experiments that wouldn't,
you wouldn't expect to turn out that
way.
So those are the trading experiments.
And I told you about them,
I think,
if I remember correctly.
So the deal is we'll play,
the three of us will play.
So I'm going to,
I have $100 and you can have as much of
it as you want,
but you have to give him some and he has
to accept your offer.
So I've got a hundred how much are you
going to give him?
30 would you take that?
Okay.
Now,
so,
so what,
what's been found everywhere is that
people roughly center around 50 50 and
so even if the amounts are quite high,
and even if the people to whom the money
is being offered are very poor,
in fact,
the poor the people are to whom the
money is being offered,
the more likely they are to tell you to
go to hell if you're not being fair.
And so that's and that,
and they see and that's built in and you
think about that,
like it doesn't take much more than that
for morality as,
as a system to get going.
So if the rough expectation is
reciprocity,
where that's possible,
then deviations from that reciprocity
are going to be punished very harshly.
And so right there you have the grounds
for the emergence of a complex system of
human interactions.
That's by no means arbitrary.
Now it might be,
you know,
altered to some degree by the
particularities of the local
environment.
There's no doubt about that.
But something can have a fundamental
pattern and still be capable of,
you know,
a large number of variants.
So,
so what that essentially means,
and this is exactly what piaget
observed,
is that when you put people together,
which you do because people can't live
by themselves,
were highly social creatures.
We have a long period of dependence,
we have to make our way and you know,
the nuclear family unit,
whatever it happens to be,
then we have to adjust to the broader
group.
We have to be acceptable to the broader
And then we have to learn to maintain
the broader group and to contributed,
contribute to it.
Because if we don't,
the quality of our experience will
suffer dramatically.
So you ended up outcast or punished or
frustrated or disappointed or alone or
all the things that happen if you don't
at least uphold a fair bit of your
social responsibility.
And so what that means right away is
that the patterns that constitute
appropriate behavior are not just
arbitrary.
Now what exactly they are.
Well that's complicated.
You know,
it's just as complicated as Jane Goodall
going out into the habitat of the chimps
and watching them and trying to figure
out just exactly what those chimps are
up to and we kind of know what they're
up to.
They organize themselves and dominance
hierarchies because almost every animal
does that.
And then along with that go certain
kinds of rules of interaction.
Except they're not rules because chimps
don't have rules because chimps don't
have abstract conception.
What they have is rituals of behavior
and shared expectations.
But that's the beginning of rules,
right?
It's like Piaget says,
well to put children together when
there's seven or eight and they play
marbles,
they can all play.
But if you take them away from the group
and you ask them what the rules are,
they really don't know.
And all that means is they can dance and
they can dance with other kids,
but they can't tell you how to dance.
But that doesn't mean they don't know
how to do it.
And like we're all like that,
right?
Because we're living in these very,
very complex hierarchical environments
where we inhabit multiple hierarchies
and they're very,
very complicated and row is wandering
around trying to figure out,
well what the hell is it that we're up
to?
And we don't exactly know which is why
we need the psychology.
But just because we don't know what
we're up to doesn't mean we're not up to
something.
And it also doesn't mean that there
isn't something that we should be up to.
And I think the social interaction list
idea is even deeper than that because
almost all the time when you're
interacting with people,
they're broadcasting their desire for
you to be some sort of person,
right?
And it might be kind of like the person
you are,
but their expectations are higher than
that because they would rather in all,
especially when they're seriously
involved with you,
they would rather that you were a good
sort of person.
And that's what they demand from you.
They want you to listen to them.
They want you to treat them properly.
They want you to engage in reciprocal
trade.
They,
you know,
they want you to take care of yourself.
I'm assuming they're not all resentful
and full of hate and all that,
you know,
they're not just saying,
be yourself there saying no,
no,
no.
Be what everyone needs.
And that's what everyone is broadcasting
to everyone else all the time is like,
be what I need be.
I need be what I need,
be what they need.
And so you're,
you're,
you're always being told the message
from people,
even if they're just raising their
eyebrows at you are smiling or not
smiling or calling you on the phone or
texting you or not doing that.
You're just being informed about who you
should be all the time.
And there's no reason to assume that's
arbitrary either.
Given that we share a common biological
ground and we have the same emotions,
roughly speaking,
and we have the same motivations,
roughly speaking.
So given that pattern that you know,
ground of commonality and expectation,
well why should we assume anything other
than a pattern,
a pattern,
emergence of agreement out of that.
So,
so the moral relativists theory assumes
that morality is relative.
And I think that's a naive theory.
It seems to me that it's relative and
non relative,
which means there are elements of it
that are fixed and necessarily so.
And then there are other things that can
vary without,
you know,
without a problem as long as people
agreed to it.
But I think that societies,
and this is also a Piagetian notion,
that societies that violate the
principle of reciprocity are not very
stable because no one's pleased by those
circumstances.
Some people are slaves and some people
are tyrants and you know,
that'll work for a while,
but it's unstable.
And even within a family,
it's the same thing.
If your father is a complete bloody
tyrant,
what you're going to do is either be
crushed and useless or get the hell away
from there as fast as you can.
It's not a stable solution.
So,
and you know,
nonreciprocal relations at any level of,
of interaction are not,
they're not tenable.
And they also,
they shouldn't be tenable,
you know,
so when you see people in psychotherapy,
especially if they tend to be on the
agreeable side,
one of the things that you teach them is
how to speak more about their own needs
so to speak,
or that or their own desires of their
own values so that the probability that
they'll engage in a prop in a truly
reciprocal relationship starts to
increase.
They won't be taken advantage of so
much.
And that seems to be a necessary
precondition for their satisfactory
embeddedness in a social context,
satisfactory being something that you
are doing and that you can maintain and
are willing to maintain.
Right.
Because a real relationship is a game
you play over and over and over and over
and you're not going to want to play
with someone who doesn't play fair.
So even little kids know that and they
know it deeply.
So the,
the moral relativism theory is a foolish
and,
and it's,
it's,
it's foolish and ill researched.
Yeah.
At the bottom of the being and becoming
question is something else and this is
something that they existential
philosophers and the young Ian's and
most religious systems concentrate on,
which is sort of what,
what's the core nature of being and
when,
when systems have that sort of
discussing the coordinator of being one
of the immediate objects of
contemplation is the fact that human
beings are limited,
right?
There's lots of things we can't do.
For example,
you're there and you're not there.
You know,
you're then that's thrown this from a
fund.
From a phenomenological perspective,
you're just stuck with what you are,
you know,
we are a certain height,
you have certain eye color,
your certain amount of attractive or or
not,
you know,
you're verbally fluent,
you're smart or you're not,
or you're conscientious like,
and it's just sort of those are the
cards that you've been dealt and really
is worth thinking about it that way.
Because who you are in some sense is a
consequence of a lot of processes,
genetic processes that are in some ways
random and you've been dealt in
particular hand and then you have to
play it.
And that hand has limitations.
And so people in some sense are there
offered opportunities by the nature of,
of their,
of,
of how they're constituted.
But there's also a tragic element to
that,
which is well,
as you move in life,
you bump up against limitations that you
cannot transcend.
You know,
and those are the typical limitations.
You bumped up against the demands of the
social group,
which has a tyrannical element.
You bump up against nature itself
because you're susceptible to illness
and to degeneration and to,
and eventually to death.
And so are the people around you.
And so there's this,
there's this issue at the bottom of
being that also presents you with a
problem.
So life is problematic.
You're trying to solve it and that's
what you're stuck with.
So that's sort of the parameters of
being.
And so I think in in most mythological
language,
I like to think of mythology,
philosophy and then mythology as like
forms of conceptualization that are
examining the grammatical structure of
being.
It's like what's common among sets of
people,
what,
what's common to the experience of sets
of people.
And the fact that you are is one of
them.
And the fact that the fact that you are
has problems is another.
And then a third one is while you're
motivated at least to some degree to do
something about those things.
And so that's what makes people human.
And in many regards it's something
fundamental that makes them human.
So you can think about that as tragic
self consciousness.
It's self conscious because you know who
you are and it's tragic because you also
know where your limitations are and
their fundamental.
And that also sets up another set of
motivations,
which is,
well,
is there something we can do about this?
Can we limit our vulnerability?
Can we extend our scope of power?
And how do we do that without causing
more trouble than we're solving?
So with that kind of common problem at
the basis of our being,
that's also what enables us to
communicate because we understand each
other because we're in the same states
of being.
So you can talk to someone about your
problems without having to explain what
problems are because you can't
communicate with people unless there's
some things you don't have to
communicate about.
It need a shared set of assumptions.
And one of them is,
for example,
that you have problems and now is that
maybe you're looking for solutions.
Another is that may be communication
about that is helpful.
You know,
none of those things have to be
established before you start
communicating because everyone's already
got that.
Those presuppositions built right into
their understanding.
So I've modeled this,
you've seen this lots of times now and
I've sort of modeled this like this and
this is a cybernetic model in many ways
and it's based,
although I didn't know it when I
developed it,
I was based on the thinking of Norbert
Wiener who was an artificial
intelligence genius and it basically
presumes that it's a modified version.
It presumes that wherever you are,
you have some conception of where you
are.
That's your current understanding of the
world.
It's flawed.
Just because you're here doesn't mean
you understand everything about being
here.
Hopefully because you have low
resolution conceptions,
you don't know anything about the people
around you.
As long as they sit down and shut up and
act normally,
that's no problem because you can easily
ignore them,
but they're full of weird potential and
God only knows when that's going to
emerge from one of them.
But,
so I'm saying,
you know where you are,
you have a model of what you are but
it's shallow and potentially flawed.
And part of the reason that you can get
away with that is because there's all
this,
there's this implicit agreement among
all of us not to do anything that
violates general social expectation.
And so that's partly how you can get
away with the fact that you don't know
anything about anyone.
It's like,
yeah,
there peculiar like rhinoceroses and
ostriches and God only knows what
they're up to,
but hopefully they're socialized enough
so they don't show you how peculiar they
are when you're walking past them on the
street in Po,
in public.
And so you can get away with your
shallow knowledge.
So,
and then you have some sense of where
you're going and you know,
maybe that's vague part of it.
It's going to be there whether you have
thought it through or not.
And the reason for that is,
as we've discussed,
the biologists are pretty good at
informing us on this part is that,
you know,
at the base of your cognitive,
emotional,
motivational,
perceptual structure that gives rise to
your being are the systems that are
going to push you in some direction as a
motivation systems or emotion system.
So if you don't drink water long enough,
pretty much that's all you're going to
be able to think about and value.
And not only that,
see the world through.
Cause when you see the world as a
thirsty person,
you're not seeing the world the same way
that someone who has had plenty to drink
sees it.
So,
and also you have this,
this space that defines where you are
and this conception about where you're
going and you think where you're going
is better.
And you have a theory about how you're
going to transform the present into the
more desirable future.
But you can make an error at any level
of that conceptualization.
And that sort of a modification of
Jeffrey Gray's theory,
the cybernetic theorist,
because what they believed was that you
see the world,
you expect certain things to happen when
you act and now and then when you act,
that expectation has violated.
And so then you have to reconfigure your
behavior or your conception of the
future.
But that's not quite right because you
don't see the world,
right?
You perceive the world through a fog of,
of preconceptions and in a manner that's
um,
impaired because of your tremendous
cognitive limitations.
And what that means is that when you're
wrong,
you can be wrong anywhere in that model.
You can be wrong because you don't know
where you are.
You can be wrong because you picked the
wrong behaviors to manifest.
Or you can be wrong because your
conception of where you're going is
flawed in that you're not going to be
happy when you get there.
Or maybe it doesn't even exist.
And I think you see this most painfully
when you're in a relationship and you're
be trade.
Because if you're in a relationship and
you're betrayed by someone,
then it's pretty damn clear that you
didn't know where you were.
Now it's also then clear.
You don't know where you're going and
also that you probably don't know what
you're doing.
So that's very painful.
But it's in human relationships in
particular.
I think that you find out how fragile
your conceptions of the present actually
are and that you're not dealing with the
world.
You're dealing with a very
oversimplified and presupposition based
conception of the world.
You know?
Cause maybe you think your partner loves
you and is trustworthy and maybe you
think all people are trustworthy,
you know,
because you're naive and then you find
out,
well if that's love you don't want any
of it and they're not trustworthy.
And then then what the hell?
It's like,
well you don't know where you are.
You don't know where you're going.
You probably don't know who you are
anymore.
You certainly don't know who the hell
that person is.
And because you don't know who they are
or you are,
then maybe you don't know who anyone is.
And that puts you in a place too.
And so one of the things that I've
thought for a substantial amount of time
is that you can think about that.
I'll go back like this.
When you're thinking about the structure
of the world,
and one element of the structure is that
there's the place.
Those are two serpents,
by the way,
I just found out about that recently
too.
Snakes,
very common mythological motif.
They represent.
This is Dow,
right from the Taoists,
from from,
from Taoism,
and from the Dow is thinkers.
And Dow basically means something like
being or something like the way,
which is like the path of life and it's
more a phenomenological than scientific.
What it's basically saying is that your
experience is composed of two domains,
always necessarily.
One domain is the orderly domain and the
orderly domain is the place where when
you act,
what you expect,
habits or,
or more precisely.
It's the place where when you act,
what you want happens,
and that's orderly because you
understand it well enough so that,
so that the snakes don't escape.
When you walk forward,
you know,
you're,
you're
limited.
Preconceptions are sufficient so that
they map onto the environment as it
emerges,
as you act.
That's an orderly place and fine,
that's not a bad place.
You know,
it's like most of you want most of your
experience to be that kind of place
because otherwise it's just too
overwhelming.
Right?
But the problem with order is that you
can have too much order and,
and all the variability of your
experience can be pushed out and then
you get bored.
So the answer isn't total order.
And we've also talked about what happens
when the answer becomes total order,
right?
Cause that's the totalitarian solution.
And we kind of think that maybe it's
grounded in not only in fear but also in
discussed or maybe mostly in disgust.
And so the,
the,
the opposite of the ordered low lead
domain seems to be the chaotic domain.
And the chaotic domain is where you are
when you don't know where you are.
And that's not a geographical place,
although it can be,
because you can get last say in the city
and then you're in chaos.
But it's more like a,
it's more often I think in an
interpersonal place.
No,
I think people encounter chaos most
often and it's deep sense within their
relationships with other people go
seriously wrong.
And so that's when you're confronted
with all the things you don't know.
It's also,
it also happens to you a lot when you
were interacting with complex
technological machinery and it fails on
you because as soon as it fails,
it's like,
well at one second it's,
it's your little gray box with keys that
you could push.
And if the next second it's God only
knows what,
and you are certainly not capable of
generally speaking of dealing with that.
So the Dow is say,
well,
the world is made up of Yin and Yang.
That's how they,
that's the terms that they use to
conceptualize it.
And that's often translated.
As you know,
Yang is masculine and Yin is feminine,
but that doesn't mean male and female.
It means something deeper,
which is human beings have a social
cognitive architecture.
And so you know,
we're,
we're from from time in memorial where
we're used to mapping the world as
masculine and feminine because most of
our interactions throughout our
evolutionary history have been social
and interpersonal interactions.
That's the primary reality.
And when we developed our,
you know,
greater cognitive capacity and our
ability to abstract,
we had to use the conceptual structures
that we'd already evolved in order to
start mapping out the world abstractly.
And so we seem to use masculine and
feminine,
which is sort of like the primary binary
opposition to represent things that are
primarily opposed at the deepest of
levels.
There's other reasons as well.
I mean chaos is the place from which new
things emerge.
So if your computer crashes and you have
to learn to fix it,
then you've learned,
you've extracted a whole bunch of
information from what was otherwise just
a black box so to speak.
And that makes you more skillful and it
makes your understanding of the world,
your detailed representation of the
world more differentiated.
So chaos is the place that new
information comes out of.
And that's partly also why it's
feminine,
because the feminine is that from which
new things emerge.
And of course the orderly element is
masculine,
at least in part because we tend to
conceive of dominance hierarchies as
something like a patriarchal structure.
And they are something like that.
They're like that among human beings.
And they also seem to be like that among
chimpanzees,
although not so much with the barnacles.
So,
so that's an interesting way of thinking
about things.
And the taoists would say those are
universal elements of being,
no matter where you are,
there's things you know and there's
things you don't know.
And so that's the fundamental problem in
your life.
How to deal with the things you know and
can predict and want and how to deal
with the things that you can't.
And then the Dallas would also say,
well,
you should walk the line between them.
That's the right place to be.
And that's a very,
very,
very smart way of thinking about it.
Because if you're only ever where you
know what's going to happen to,
you've got two problems.
One is you're not learning anything
because of what you already know is
already working.
So why bother changing it?
The second is worse because order tends
to deteriorate of its own accord,
right?
Because the world itself continues to
change.
Just entropy will make a change.
And so if all you do is stick yourself
inside the order,
the order itself over time is going to
get less and less stable.
And then at some point it's not going to
be there at all and you'll fall right
into chaos.
So you can't just hide over where
everything is predictable and where you
get what you want.
On the other hand,
if you're in chaos all the time and you
never know what's going on,
then you can't tolerate that
physiologically because the closer you
are to serious chaos,
the more your body is preparing for the
worst.
And that's because at the bottom of
chaos is the worst,
right?
So you see in mythological
representations,
chaos is the underworld.
And in underworld there's hell and hell
is like the worst place in chaos.
And when you think about conceptions
like this,
when people say,
well,
do those places exist?
And the answer to that is,
well it depends on what you mean by
exist.
Does the domain of chaos exist?
Well,
how many of you have been there as soon
as you know the language,
you think,
oh yeah,
that exists.
I've been where chaos is Lourdes maybe
more than I want to be and now and then
I've even been in that part of chaos
that's best described as hell.
So that's the sort of chaos that you
visit where everything you do makes it
worse.
And you know,
I'm sure that people,
at least some of you have been in that
situation,
you know where things went wrong.
And then because of your own foolishness
or because of the malevolence of other
people,
you know,
the situation develops so that it went
from bad to horrible with each success
of decision.
That's a place that people can go.
It's very,
it's a very real place,
might be more real than anything else.
So the Dow is say,
well,
you know the chaos issue while you,
you just can't tolerate too much of
that.
What your body does when it doesn't know
what's going on is basically prepare you
for anything that might happen.
You know,
and that's uh,
that's the generalized stress response
and that's associated with massive
release of cortisol and that puts you on
alert and that's great.
You're awake and ready,
but you know,
couple of years of that,
then you're old.
Your body just cannot tolerate that
level of energy expenditure on a
constant basis.
It wears you out,
it makes you old fundamentally,
so bored or terrified.
Those are sort of the,
the extremes of chaos in order.
Let's say if you're on the line down the
middle,
well then it's,
you're secure enough so you're not
experiencing a level of negative emotion
that's intolerable.
A little apprehension.
That might be a good thing.
You know,
imagine that you're preparing to meet
someone that you're interested in.
Well,
is the apprehension a good part of that
or bad part?
Like would you do without that?
Well,
you might,
if it's like paralyzing you to the point
where you can hardly even go through
with talking to them.
But if it's just part of expectation,
that's part of excitement,
you know?
So
when you're on that border between chaos
and order,
you don't want to be so orderly that
you're entirely comfortable.
And that's partly because you're asleep.
Then like,
why the hell do you have to be awake if
everything's going your way,
you know?
And if you're driving home in your car
and nothing is going on,
you're kind of not even there.
You know,
maybe you're thinking about things in
the future,
but you're certainly not attending in
any real deep sense to what's going on
around you.
And that's because you don't have to,
well,
when you're a little apprehensive,
well then your call,
you're more conscious,
you know?
And then you're more engaged in reality.
And then there's the positive emotions
that are associated with that too,
which is excitement and enthusiasm and
curiosity and hope and all those things
are in some sense,
all those things are worth living for.
And part of the reason that the taoists
believed that you should walk the line
between chaos and order is because it's
at that place where the quality of your
existence is high enough.
So that the problems that we discussed,
the existential problems we discussed
are no longer particularly relevant.
And you know,
you might say,
well what's the meaning of life?
And I might say,
well,
you can't really ask that question
linguistically cause there isn't a
linguistic answer just as the problem
itself isn't linguistic,
right?
Suffering is not the word.
Suffering.
Suffering is something that you embody
and meaning is not the word,
meaning it's something that happens to
you.
And so the Dallas would say,
well,
stand on the line between order and
chaos.
You can tell when you're there because
you're awake and alert and excited and
enthusiastic and deep into the moment.
And that's a good place to be.
And I think the reason that your nervous
system does that to you,
and this is an evolved issue,
is that your brain wants you to be on
the line between order and chaos because
that's where dynamic stability is best
to tate,
right?
Because your problem is how do you
maintain yourself,
right?
Then the problem is how do you maintain
yourself optimally?
And then the problem is how do you
maintain yourself optimally in a world
that continues to transform and answer
to that isn't while you stand still,
the answer to that is you,
you transform yourself at the rate that
keeps you in sync with the transforming
environment.
And since we're adapted to transforming
environments,
there's no reason to assume that when
you feel the best about what you're
doing,
so to speak,
there's no reason to assume that that's
not exactly where you should be.
Why else would you feel like that
engaged and interested and not plagued
by a surf bite of say,
existential problems.
And so then meaning becomes something
you discover an attempt to inhabit
rather than some conceptual answer to a
conceptual problem.
So it's a very interesting idea.
And I think the psychophysiological
evidence for its validity is quite
strong.
You know,
we talked about how the hypothalamus is
constructed.
For example,
we know that it,
you know,
the hypothalamus is concerned with a lot
of the basic things that you need to do
to survive.
So it's always throwing up these little
motivated schemes through which you have
to view the world,
fine,
you have to deal with those.
But when you have dealt with them
it defaults to mild exploration and
that's governed by you know,
by pain and by fear and by disgust
because you can't have your exploration
be entirely unbridled.
But the optimal state of existence looks
like something like,
yeah,
engaged interest with what's going on
without too much apprehension now,
not with the zero apprehension because
the apprehension also wakes you up a bit
and that's the place where information
flow is maximized.
That's the place where you become more
than you currently are.
And that's the place where your,
your description of the world becomes
deeper and deeper than the one you
already have.
So that's the place where you get to
have your cake and eat it too
sufficiently secure,
but also engaged in a game that ensures
that that security maintains itself
across time.
So,
so you know,
if your life is composed of order and
chaos in a sense and an that's part of
your fundamental existential problem,
how to deal with chaos,
how to deal with too much order.
In some sense,
your nervous system already sets you up
for that now.
And that's associated with some of the
deeper ideas that have been put forward
by people like young and then to a
lesser degree by people like Rogers and
Maslow who believed in something like
human potential or human self
actualization and unions idea was a
deeper idea that matt was that when
you're operating on the border between
order and chaos and you're interested in
something,
that's where,
that's when you're where you are.
That's when you're there,
you're interested in something and
you're captivated by it.
You would then say if you try to stay
there,
which means you follow that,
it will take you to all the places that
you don't want to go.
It'll take you to all the places in your
past that you haven't made complete use
of,
and it'll take you to all those places
that you're avoiding in the future and
the present.
That's what that mechanism is for.
And the reason it will do that is
because with all those experiences that
you've had in the past that you've
avoided or you haven't made thorough use
of,
there's still sort of latent world left
there.
So you know,
you see this with people in their
relationships.
It's like say say a woman is going out
with an abusive guy.
She finally dropped some and it's like
boom,
next relationship.
Oh look,
it's another abusive guy.
And then she drops him and then the next
relationship it's like,
hmm,
it's another abusive guy.
And Freud called that the repetition
compulsion.
But you might think,
well,
what is missing in her world view that
makes it such that when she acts,
she keeps running into the same
obstacle.
It's like her map isn't correct.
And so then you might say,
well if she went back to the first
relationship and really dug around in
the carcass so to speak,
she might find out what the hell she's
missing.
One thing might be,
well,
when exactly do you say no and how do
you say it?
You know,
because abuse for example usually starts
out like it rarely starts out that the
person is calm and then you end up
pounded flat.
It's like the person who's prone to
abuse as disagreeable.
And so they'll push you and then what
happens next?
Depends on how you respond and if you
step back and you step back and you step
back and you keep doing that,
the probability that the aggression,
the person can't control the aggression
say,
cause they're not well socialized unless
you put a limit on it,
it's,
it's just going to chase you.
It's going to get bigger and bigger as
you step backwards and like very many
things are like that in life.
So then you think,
well you have to make enough use of
what's around you of what you haven't
explored to repair yourself in some
sense.
Or to flesh yourself out so that you're
capable of saying no,
that's not going to happen in a way that
actually increases the probability that
it's not going to happen.
Now I'm certainly not saying that you
know,
everybody's in a,
in an abusive relationship deserves to
be in what I'm talking about,
a very specific set of circumstances
where the same damn thing happens over
and over because then you have to ask,
well is this random or is there
something going on that increases the
probability of that outcome.
Now he owns ideas.
There are very strange ideas cause they
take you deep into mythology and we can,
we can look back at that a little.
Yeah.
All right.
So the idea,
well you've got this little framework
that you have to look at the world
through.
It tells you approximately where you
are,
approximately,
where you need to go and approximately
what you should do to get there.
But it can be wrong in any level of
analysis.
So then you ask,
well,
what produces those little worlds and
what answers?
One answer is basic biological
necessity,
right?
So the basic motivational systems,
emotional systems,
the lines are blurry partly to keep you
on track,
right?
You're hungry when your blood sugar
falls,
you're thirsty when you haven't,
when you're not sufficiently hydrated.
Obviously you're sleepy when you've gone
without sleep for too long,
et Cetera,
et cetera.
And there that those things have been
problems for so long that in some sense
you have machinery that takes care of
that.
Okay,
so that's,
that's model there.
I started roughly broke the fundamental
motivations into those that keep you
going and those that help you propagate
because in some sense,
those are the two Darwinian problems
that you have to solve in life.
But then you might think,
this seems to me to be how you can start
to think about how the traits might be
organized into this narrative scheme.
It's like the traits seemed to me,
maybe there's a hundred now,
maybe there's 30
motivational states,
some of them are pure motivational
states,
maybe in some of them are just
combinations of motivational states,
but they're like the basic elements of
motivation and then maybe they clump
together in five different ways.
And out of that we get the five traits
and then the five traits are like,
they're kind of like the preconditions
for your particular story.
So if you're a conscientious person,
then the world is a little less orderly
and little less well put together then
it should be.
And your story is,
I'm the person who goes in there and fix
that up and makes it orderly.
And you know,
if you're an extroverted person then you
think,
well,
um,
there's all that social territory out
there to occupy and exploit and,
and I'm the sort of person that is
really going to do that because that's
where your interests lie.
And if you're an open person,
it's like,
wow,
look at all these weird things that I
can do and think about.
And so that's the world for you.
And those are all,
you can think of those as a set of five
stories in some sense that have a
reasonable probability of success.
So there are five modes of being and
they're composed of these more
fragmented fundamental motivations and
something like that.
It's so that,
that's sort of where you can start to
see the concordance between the
narrative theories of the clinicians and
the trait theories of the empiricists.
And there has been work done on this
sort of thing.
So we know,
for example,
that,
um,
Jacob Hersch did some of this work that
your trade temperament does influence
the words that you use to describe your,
your spontaneous self narratives.
So if I say write about your past and
then I analyze your word use,
I can make an educated guess about
whether you're extroverted or
introverted or conscientious or open or
agreeable.
So,
and then Dan Mcadams has showed that,
you know,
you know how the big five clump into
plasticity and stability.
You can,
the plastic people produce more
exploratory narratives and the stable
people produce narratives that are more
associated with,
you know,
security in order.
So,
so there hasn't been a lot of work done
at the interface between traits and
narratives,
but you know,
so I'm sort of pushing the limits of
knowledge here,
but,
but I think that's the direction in
which the integration will likely take
place.
Okay.
And then we talked a little bit about
how emotion might work too.
And so we say,
well,
you're in this little motivated state so
it tells you something about where you
are and what that's like.
And it gives you some hints about where
you might go with that and a disinhibit
the relevant behaviors that would be
associated with that,
including perceptual behaviors.
And then you walk forward,
well what happens?
Well two things roughly can happen.
Things you want,
which indicates a,
that you're moving towards the goal and
B,
that your plan is good,
right?
It indicates both and that that's
positive emotion,
right?
That's incentive reward.
That's dopaminergic be mediated and you
like that as long as it's not too
intense.
And then the next that can happen is
two things.
There's,
there's,
it can be divided into two,
there are things you don't want to have
happen.
And some of those are,
well there's just an obstacle in your
way and with a minor deviation in terms
of trajectory,
you can walk around it and then the
other is something you completely don't
understand how it was and it just knocks
the bottom out of your stupid plant.
And then it also might knock the bottom
out of all sorts of other plans as well,
depending on how unexpected it is.
And that seems to me to be where the
transition from order to chaos occurs.
So your,
we use a relationship example again,
you go home to invite your girlfriend
out to have dinner and you find out that
she's in bed with someone else.
It's like,
well,
dinner's off.
Right,
right.
Okay.
But that's not all that's off.
Right.
So then you might think,
okay,
well there's a lot of things all of a
sudden that are off because that's a
much bigger catastrophe.
Then if she says,
well,
I already made dinner and you know,
maybe you're a little irritated because
you can't take her out now and,
but,
and you have to eat something else.
It's like,
oh,
well that's not such a catastrophe.
But it's not easy to figure out exactly
why those catastrophes differ because
they're both unexpected things.
And so then you have to think,
well,
one of them disrupt seems to disrupt a
lot more than the other.
And then you have to think,
well,
disrupt what?
And then that's why I talked to you guys
about this is because I,
and this is p a jetty.
And in some sense I think this is the
way to understand why you get upset when
you get upset.
It's like,
okay,
well,
you know,
you wanted to take your girlfriend out
for dinner and you know how to do that.
You'd go into the elevator,
you take the elevator down,
you eat,
you pay,
you know it's,
it's behaviorally plotted out quite
well.
And so there's a bunch of behaviors at
the bottom.
And then there's the,
you know,
the,
the label go out for dinner and it's a
little thing down at the bottom and it
gets disrupted.
And so you're sort of upset in
proportion to that little bit of
territory that's been bent a stray.
And maybe if you're not too emotionally
unstable or neurotic,
maybe it's a pretty seamless transition,
you know?
Whereas if you're say emotionally stable
and extroverted,
you think,
oh good,
something new,
you know,
so,
and both of those responses are
understandable.
All right,
but when it's,
you know,
your partner is in bed with someone
else,
it's sort of more like at the top,
which is well your say your conception
of your,
the quality of your life for the overall
quality of you,
Ethan.
And when something major happens,
it's like,
it blows apart,
potentially blows apart your entire
structure.
Partly your conceptual structure.
Because like,
Whoa,
what the hell did you know?
Like how stupid could you possibly be?
And that tells you exactly how stupid
you can be.
But then you start to wonder about why
it happened to you.
And partly that's because you're stupid.
Or at least that's what you think.
But then it's also because,
well maybe there's a whole bunch of
skills that you don't have.
Like,
you know,
if you were a better person,
if you were more interesting,
if you went,
you know more places,
if you were more caring,
if you weren't quite as selfish,
if you were more conscientious,
right?
Because then you start to think,
well,
what do I lack?
It's not only what have I missed
perceived,
it's what do I lack?
And when you get hit at a high level,
like your partner be tracy you,
it's like you're infinitely stupid and
you're infinitely worthless and that's
chaos.
And so then you're in chaos and well
what then do you do?
Well,
the best answer to that is you avoid it
to begin with.
You take the steps along the way that
decrease the probability that you're
ever going to end up there.
And that's
in some sense that's what that means.
So you know,
if you look at this conceptualization,
you can kind of see you're moving from
point a to point b and then the
unpredicted outcome is like a hole in
your plan.
It's like that's not supposed to happen.
Because if you had a good plan,
something you didn't want to have
happened wouldn't have happened.
And so it's like a hole in your plan and
then you fall through the hole and you
find out how big the hole is.
And maybe it's a hole that just ate that
plan.
And so who cares?
Or maybe it's the kind of hold it just
keeps growing until all of you falls
into it.
All right,
so
how do you deal with that as a
possibility?
Especially given that you have limited
knowledge and so that's what this means
and this is the same thing basically as
the taoists representation.
Because the dow representation Dow also
means meaning,
Hey,
and so being on that line between chaos
and order is meaningful and the taoists
believed that you should be where things
are meaningful.
That's the right place to be.
And you think,
well,
it's a good place to be if you think
about it,
about you know,
your own experiences.
When you're doing something meaningful,
you think you don't even think about it,
it's just this is a good place to be and
you can notice it.
Maybe you can notice it and continue to
do it more.
And that's what the existentialists
would call striving for an authentic
existence.
You know when you can think about that
as well,
it's philosophy.
It's like,
no,
don't,
don't be thinking that.
It's advice about how to structure your
life so that it's quality is sufficient
so that you don't become resentful and
full of hate.
Like it's not casual.
Well,
here's some philosophical ideas to think
about.
It's like you got a take this seriously
because if you don't,
not only do you not have a good time
because you just aren't paying any
attention,
but you'll also turn into the sort of
person who's highly motivated to make
sure that no one else ever has a good
time as well.
And so you go from just kind of being
useless and miserable on your own.
When that becomes sufficient,
Lee,
useful and meaningless and painful,
then you're undoubtedly going to start
to dream about taking it out on all the
other people whose fault it is that
you're unfulfilled and miserable.
And so it doesn't,
if you don't stay in that meaningful
place.
So to speak so that your life is
acceptable to you.
You don't think that you're the only one
who will suffer.
It's you're just the beginning of the
suffering.
Now with this,
this is a great,
this is a great image.
It's really old.
You know the oldest story we have,
which is called the Enuma elish.
I told you a little bit about it.
The Sumerian creation myth is the myth
about a hero basically going out to
conquer some vaguely reptilian dragon
ish,
chaos beast.
And
that's really,
as far as I can tell,
that's really the story of humanity
there and the story of humanity is you
look on the,
on the right,
there's a,
there's a whole,
that's the whole that your plans,
that's the whole that you fall into when
your plans don't work.
So that hole is always there and at the
bottom of the hole is something terrible
and that's what the dragon is.
And then the little castle at the
background,
well that's order,
that's where you live.
And this thing that crawls out of the
hole to face you is always threatening
order and answer is well then what you
do about it.
And one answer is man,
get those walls up,
you know,
800 stories tall and 500 feet thick.
And the problem is,
well you can't get out of a castle
that's that thick.
So maybe that's not so good.
You know?
And the other thing is just to throw
your hands up in despair and say,
well what the hell is the use of having
a castle anyways if there's just going
to be dragons around it.
And then the other one is,
well maybe we should take care of it
when it's relatively small.
And so,
you know,
when you're in a relationship,
for example,
if you don't want it to fall down a pet,
then you have to notice when the little
dragons are popping up.
You know?
And those are things that disturb your
equilibrium that produced some negative
emotion.
But that also sort of call out to you,
this isn't acceptable.
I should do something about it.
And the most important ones to not avoid
are the ones that call out to you.
This isn't good.
I should do something about it.
I know what to do and I could do it.
And if you step back from that,
well then all that'll happen is those
things will multiply and multiply and
multiply and multiply until they're so
big that you're no match for them
whatsoever.
You'll trip over it,
fall down that hole.
And that'll be that.
And so that's a bad outcome.
So that's part of the moral obligation.
Say that the existentialists lay on
people in the unions as well.
It's like wake up,
pay attention.
You know,
if things going the way that you want
them to then do what you can as fast as
you can to stay something about it and
fix it,
fix it.
Do the things you can to repair the
things around you that are producing low
quality experience.
And then what happens?
Well,
you get tougher,
and the reason you get tougher is
because you're engaged in all these
little micro battles,
and the more you engage in those micro
battles,
the better you get at battling.
And so then you become someone who can
say no when you have to say no,
and that's a really useful thing to be
able to say.
Then also,
the other thing you're doing is that,
well,
everything around you is trying to turn
into chaos and the chaos is popping up.
You're just like,
it's like whackable,
you know that foolish arcade game parks,
the little weasel,
and you hit it with the stick.
It's like,
well,
that's what it's like.
Little problems pop up.
Fix them as soon as they pop up because
then they can't grow.
Well,
maybe they still will,
but at least you'll have the best
probability that they won't grow
unnecessarily.
All right,
so that's what I've derived from what
I've
taught to you.
People.
You know that,
that
the fundamental problems of life are
existential.
It's what to do.
The solutions to those problems are not
arbitrary.
The wisdom traditions of mankind and the
profound psychological theories that
we've collected over the last 200 years.
They converge.
You know,
one of,
one of the things they say is get your
story straight.
And other thing they say is if you're
avoiding something that you need to do
in order to get to where you're going,
quit avoiding it because the avoidance
will cause you trouble.
It'll,
it'll weaken you and it'll make the
world into a more terrible place.
And then the,
the broader sociological,
psychological studies,
like the ones that were done by people
like soldier Hanson,
who as you know,
isn't generally utilized in a
personality class,
but he's sort of like a metta,
Viktor Frankl,
as far as I'm concerned,
you know,
a soldier and instant lays out.
Another problem with all of this,
which is,
well,
if you don't do this,
if you don't get your story straight and
you don't stop avoiding,
well then,
well,
what's the consequence in one
consequences while you're a miserable
thing with a very low quality life.
And so you're just going to be tortured
by existence and it's perfectly capable
of torturing you beyond your endurance.
And that sort of sucks for you.
But the next step beyond that is why you
become the sort of person who isn't
really all that positively predisposed
to existence.
And once you're that sort of person than
anybody who comes along to offer you the
opportunity to live inside something
rigid and hurt,
anyone who comes near,
you're going to jump on that partly
because you're afraid and they offer you
security.
And partly because you're resentful and
bitter and full of hatred.
And so you're just waiting for the
bloody opportunity to take that out on
someone,
especially if you can act morally and
superior.
Well,
you're doing it,
you know,
and you think,
well,
that's basically what Hitler offered the
Germans.
And that's basically what Stalin offered
the communists.
It was an inversion of the order.
And anybody who is pathologically
resentful had the opportunity to be just
as murderous as they wanted to be.
And so,
you know,
the 20th century put towards this a
whole variety of problems.
One problem was the problem of meaning.
You know,
Nicha sort of announced that at the end
of the 19th century and then the 20th
century was,
well,
what do we do about that?
And a lot of it was nihilistic and lot
of it was totalitarian.
And both of those seem to be not so
good.
You know?
And,
and for me,
especially in the universities,
denialism hasn't ended.
It's still infested most of the
humanities.
But the nihilism in the totalitarianism,
they are not the only opportunities.
They're not the only options.
And you know,
it is possible for people to pay
attention to their lives in such a way
that they straightened out.
And if you straighten out,
man,
you'd get tough and you get useful.
And if you're tough and useful than life
isn't so horrible,
or if it,
even if it is,
you can hack it,
you know,
because make in life not horrible.
Mm.
You'll have limited success with that,
but making yourself tough enough so that
won't corrupt you.
That's a possibility.
And then the upside to that is,
well,
you're not going to be a totalitarian
then.
You're not going to be nihilistic and
you're not going to be like a primary
danger to the structure of the social
unit around you.
And who knows?
Maybe it's even better than that.
You'll be good for you.
That'd be good.
You be good for your family.
You'd be good for your community.
That would be good.
That's an equivalent rated state from
the [inaudible] perspective,
right?
You're living so it works for you.
It works for your family,
works for your community.
God only knows,
maybe it even works for the planet.
I mean,
that would be the hope.
Well,
that's a pretty good thing to aim at.
And the other thing to think about in
that regard is life is hard enough.
So you need an adventure.
You need an adventure to justify it.
Like it has to be worth it.
You know,
and one adventure,
one real adventure is see if you can get
your act together.
That's hard.
And it's an adventure and it's partly an
adventure because if you make that your
primary goal,
say,
do not avoid things to tell the truth to
aim at the highest value,
things start to happen to you.
They're not things that you're
manipulating the world to get.
There just doors that start to open and
you just,
God only knows how many doors will open
to you if you do that.
And that makes things extraordinarily
interesting.
And once things are extraordinarily
interesting,
the fact that life has its limitations
and that it's full of suffering,
you think,
yeah,
well you know,
all things considered,
it's not such a bad bargain one.
And so to close,
one of the things you might ask yourself
is if you're in a situation,
if you're in a situation where
your life isn't of a sufficient quality,
then you might ask yourself,
are you doing absolutely everything you
can to fix it?
And then you might say,
well,
let's not draw any final conclusions
about the utility of existence and its
value until we're sure we've got our act
together and are seeing things straight
and that's worth pursuing.
That's what you should be learning in
university.
You know?
Cause that's the,
that's the proper path of a citizen.
It's the proper path of someone who's
attempting to put the world's straight.
And that's the best thing you can do.
And it's not only because it's right,
it's because
it's because what's right is actually
what's best for you.
So that's what I've learned from the
stuff I've been teaching you.
So thank you.
[inaudible].